[音楽]
イース7
みなさんこんにちは
tdm というベンチャー t をから来ました
羽鳥と苦労と申します
今日は皆さんに未来を自分ごとする自分ごとにするというお話をさせていただきたいと
思います
早速で皆さんちょっと上を向いていただけますでしょうか
ありがとうございます
皆さんが最後に夜空を見上げたのはいつでしょ
もしかすると先週末満月だったのでその月を見上げたよ
いう人もいるかもしれません
僕には実は忘れられない
夜空があります
僕実は大学生の時にオーストラリア環境の勉強しに留学しに行っていた
もうその時にニュージーランドが自然がすごい豊かだという
旅行に行きます
その時に卵ギターたと言う
山岡のところに行って急流下りをして
ですごく使いなので夜ご飯を食べたという
もしたらもう少ししたら寝ようかな
ちょっと寄ることでといた方がいいよと言われる
てください
その時にさっきの皆さんみたいに
女を見上げたら
満点のコストられ
あ
綺麗だーなぁ
っていうことです
でっ
この瞬間本当にほしふるよる見ないで
なんか感動してなぜだかわかんないんですけど涙が流れてき
この先に僕の心に浮かんだことは
この星空を子どもと一緒に見たいなと
これ絶対入っ者にたら考えているんです
実はまあ今もその時も子供は全然いないんですけどなぜかそういうふうに思い
それでオーストラリアに戻った後環境の勉強を続けました
環境問題のいろんなことをする水不足の問題とか記後編のも耐える
いろんなことをしているうちにどんどん自分にできることですほとんどないんじゃない
かな
制裁金でいえばーオーストラリアで起こっている大火災
これん性低木外の仕事をしながら何かできるかといったら
もしかすると募金ぐらいしかできないかもしれない
でも少なくとも僕はそのさっき見た阻止空を
子供と一緒に見るそのためにこうやってやってきたんだ
子供に誇って言える仕事がしたいそういうふうに思っていま仕事をしています
進みたい未来橋をかけようこれが僕の会社の僕が今いる会社のスローガンです
僕にとっての進みたい未来はさっきの星空を一緒に子供と見ることっ
それに向けて橋をかけるように自分でアクションをする
そのことをすごく大事にする
活動をしています
実際僕らがどんなことをしているか
けれども
石灰石石を使って新しい素材を作るということをやっています
皆さんの身の回りにある感じだったりプラスティックだったりと
それに並ぶような第三の素材当たり前の素材にしたいと思って取り組んでい
実際どういうものになる
例えば変だったり袋だったりメニュー今日だったり
はたまたお弁当の病気だった
これ全部医師からできています
僕も最初これ見たときにや絶対しじゃないでしょと思ったんですけど
医師からできます
開発のメンバーのことをよく話ししているときにこれは新しいもできたんだよね見せ
られると
今2
対しじゃないでしょ
って思っちゃうけ
今の皆さんが使っているものと装飾なく使えるものができてきました
でもなんでそもそも第三も備え
神尾プラスティックもいいものあるのに新しい素材るん
って思うかも知れませ
これさっきの話でもあったんですけど今202,000円
世界人口77億円
2050年になると97億になると言われる
神とプラスチック神はいは4億トン年間ですか
プラスチックは3億トンを使われて
これが2050年になると2倍3倍に増えていくっていう予測があります
今の中で僕たちはこの素材を使い続けられる
もっと他にもオプションがあった方がいいんじゃないかと思って
形は新しい素材をつくって皆さんに普及しよう
分
なんで切開という
世界中に on
せ国親父れないんです
資源に乏しいと言われていた日本にも240億ともあると言う
世界的に実は石灰付ける目の台湾
けれどもこれは3000億トンあるたようには3000億とがあると
もちろん他の大陸にもすごく運がやって
僕たちはこの豊富にある素材を地産地消で大事に使う
ということをやりたい
実際髪のことを考えていただくと紙を作る時すごく水を1杯
ちょっとするので
砂漠の国とか
例えば僕らがいます進出しようとしてもごれ
いう国ではなかなか作ることができません
実際72の国デー
神は作られていないって
一方でクラシックのことを考える頭
原料になる10 u
これもすごく限られた国でしか撮ることができる
でも
それに加えてプラスチック
プラスチックの袋バカって言う
指定がかかっていくという
んですけど127カ国でそんな規制が進んでいると言われてい
これに対して僕たちが今作っている石灰石から作る新しい素材は水のほとんど使わなく
ていいし
関由来の桜プラスティックの量大きくお財布ができ
というところで新しい第三極になれるんじゃないか
もう一つ僕らが当たり前にしたいとこの当たり前になる所在を使って当たり前にしたい
ことがあります
これは今までのとって作って使って捨てるという直線の経済ではなくて
使い終わったものをゴミとしてではなく
新しい資源として捉えていく
いう循環のあり方です
の循環のあり方僕たちが提供している新しい素材だとこんな風にできます
例えばこれブラインドサッカーの
最下位で使っていただいたばなーんか左側に書いてあるんですけど
これが
使い終わった後回収してプラスチックのような
スマートフォンケース図
これまでのリサイクルのあり方では絶対に考えられなかったことが僕たちの存在では
生き
why って保身素材普及させるっていう
本当にできるの結構伴って
確かにこの素材今までになかった素材なので
9分がない
みんな見慣れてないとか
しかもベンチャー企業なのであんまり信用もないという状況の中で
難しいことあげよういくらでもあります
でも皆さんの今身の回りにあるプラスチック
5作り始められたか
実は第二次世界対戦後の70年前ぐらい経った70年前から突かれ作られ始めてここ
まで復旧した素材なんです
そう考えると僕たちはこの石灰石を使って新しい当たり前をつくるってことができると
思います
僕にはもう一つ当たり前でしたよーございます
それは未来とか
世界ことを考えて行動する人を増やすことです
サステナビリティアクセラレーターという肩書で国への活動をしています
これは自分で自分のためにつけた名前
ですが
持続可能な社会への転換を加速させる人という
アクセルオープンの人という
実際普段僕が会社でどういうことをしているかと言うと
開発メンバーと話しながらこれまでのものづくりの基準だった品質とか価格とかを
下げる
に質を上げて価格を下げるということだけじゃなくてどうやったら環境負荷を下げ
られるかということを一緒に新しい物差しを作っ
もう一つやってることは会社の成績表でよく言われますが利益とか
売上これを投資家の皆さんに伝えるだけではなくて
環境に対してどれだけ貢献できた子っていうのを見える化すること
こういうことを日々や
これ今僕はさせてナビ専任者ということでやらせていただいているんですけど
専門のチームという形ではなくて将来的には自分の肩書もなくなって自分のチームも
なくなって
全部のチームにこの新しい物差しが入ったらいいなというふうに思っています
それができてうまく会社が入ったら
他の会社にも真似してもらって
それがうまくいったら僕のアクセルを踏むっていうことができたんじゃないかなと
思えると思います
最後に僕が冒頭にお話した星空で
な見直した話というのをこういう風に解釈してるよって言う
その星空を見る前までの自分にとっての自分を撮って
本当にその瞬間しかなかっ
その瞬間に楽しめるかどうかが大事だぞ
でも
とてつもなく美しい星空を見て子供と一緒にこれを見たいって思ったことで
その子どもと一緒にいる未来を自分のことだと思えるように
こうやって自分ごとの範囲を広げて
自分の進みたい未来に対してアクションをする
これができるようになった
と思います
そして自分の進みたい未来に向かって他の人にも行動してもらいたいと思って新しい
当たり前の素材をつくって皆さんにオプションを提供する
できればそれを選んだのかということをやりたくて今の会社で活動をしています
そして今日はこれだけじゃなくて自分ちょっと欲張りなのでもう一つだけやりたい
それは皆さんが進みたい未来を自分ごと化にしたいと思って今日開きました
最後に一つだけ質問です
あなたの住みたい未来はどんな未来ですか
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]